each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
and must say I'm also a proud alumni of
the microsoft corporation I just had to
share this anecdote with you is like
just absolutely tickled the death to be
here speaking to you today I I started
my career at Microsoft as a systems
engineer for it for all things
interactive television in the mid 90s I
was systems engineer in Tokyo for
Microsoft connecting 32 homes and fiber
optic cables and experimenting with
Microsoft's own interactive TV and now I
find myself coming back here with the
Microsoft Research working on xbox and
so it's really a harmonic conversion so
there anything that I've been doing
today and it's just dawned on me so I'm
just really delighted to be here so I'd
like to talk to you about the challenges
in measuring parkinson disease but
before I do that I'm going to tell you a
little bit about the Michael J Fox
foundation where the world's largest
nonprofit funder of Parkinson's disease
research and our mission is to help
accelerate the development of therapies
or Parkinson disease and hopefully one
day to help find a cure for the disease
it was founded by the actor Michael J
Fox in year two thousand and we've spent
a bit over 400 million 450 million
dollars in Parkinson's disease research
in our business model is one of urgency
and accountability eighty-nine cents of
every dollar is spent directly on
Parkinson's disease research and we work
with industry that's why I'm here one
hundred million dollars of that 450
million is bent on industry lead
projects and primarily partnering the
biotechs and pharmaceutical companies
but since my introduction in September
as the director of data science we're
here to where
I need to work with high-tech companies
so we're interested and so we want to
work with you come to us with your ideas
to partner and collaborate love to hear
your ideas so now on to the business of
objective measures of Parkinson's
disease and challenges and directions a
challenge the standard measure of
Parkinson's disease is what's called the
unified parkinson's disease rating scale
otherwise called you pers in the
industry it has four sections it's a
survey that the neurologist gives to the
Parkinson disease patients the non-water
aspects of experiences of daily living
so have you been experiencing whose
nation so you depressed those types of
categories of questions aspects of daily
living such as speech you tossing and
turning in bed these things are the
patients are required to kind of
remember how they've been feeling to the
neurologists and there's an a motor
examination which I'll get into in the
next couple of slides and finally a
survey on motor complications that ask
things like time spent with dyskinesia
dyskinesia is a symptom a side effect of
the drug levodopa which is the gold
standard therapy for parkinson's disease
it is a disease in which the motor
neurons in the brain the dopamine
neurons are dying in the
neurotransmitter dopamine is is
beginning to fade off and that is
causing the Parkinson's disease patients
to slowly decline in their capacity for
self initiated movement so let me give
you an example really quickly of what
the motor
use me of them what what the motor part
of the updrs looks like is the video on
hold on
I won't go have been
huh
go ahead and play this
I don't think the audio is going to but
this is the standard get up and go test
and then observing the patient walking
looking for arm swing and they'll rate
the school rate the patient's ability to
walk from one to five or one to four and
now this is a pull test the neurologist
is looking for how the patient recovers
from this pull test the number of steps
they take will reflect a score from zero
to four you can imagine my previous boss
changed neurologist one who was a petite
125-pound neurologist to someone that
weighed over 200 pounds you can imagine
numb with that rating how that rating
score could have changed so the point of
this is
the challenge is it's not very objective
it's a survey it's insensitive to
changes under one-year increments right
so this is what makes the cost of dual
of delivering therapies to market for
Pocket disease is so expensive and
there's not enough discriminating power
in these measures these clinical
measures for where we could stratify the
phenotypic subtypes of the disease and
this is where ambulatory mechanized gate
ambulatory mechanized measures are going
to play a key role and we've been
working at this I've been working at
this for the past ten years in my
previous role is the program manager and
manager program director manager of the
kinetics foundation we work with the
digital health group at Intel to take
upper upper body motor test battery
we've taken components of the Purdue
pegboard a movement time reaction-time
tests and these two buttons a trill test
a tremor watch was associated and we had
a test for voice and this was a this was
a an attempt to pull together what we
knew about PD upper body PD motor
symptoms and putting it into an
objective device and and we ran a
clinical trial of the 50 patients over
six months time on this device and at
the same time we funded a company called
a PDM and this is dr. Fay Horak out of
ohsu who's a scientific director of that
company and they've came out with a a
motor a six sensor system to measure
mobility for Parkinson's disease
and through the experimentation of the
mobility device they found sensitivity
specificity of the four best metrics
were instrumented timed up and go I
remember instead of just having the
neurologist watch someone walked up and
down a hallway now we have things like
peak arm swing velocity cadence peak
trunk rotation velocity average turning
velocity the turning seems to be the
most specific and it's an eight king
it's hard to game anecdotally I remember
when dr. fake Iraq first came out with
these measures she was very excited she
came to our office and she strapped me
up with the devices and she made me do a
timed up and go and then she gave the
same set of sensors to Andy Grove it was
also Parkinson's disease patient and
make him go down the home line came came
back and he saw that the time it took
for him to come back the chair was
slower than mine so he just claimed that
he didn't understand the point of the
test so he said I gotta do it again if a
kiss her okay okay but please you know
just walk normally you're supposed to
walk my it's not a competition because I
got I got again so he goes walks and
then but then his turning is something
that he could not game because it
requires balance and so that was a very
telltale sign that his cadence it
increased he reduced the time that he
went faster than I did coming back to
the chair but we could see very clearly
in the gyroscopic information that the
turn did not improve so I think this is
really the value of these instrumented
measures and over here we have the
stride time so the coefficient of COV is
the standard deviation over the mean of
strike times for a two minute walk and
you can see that
the variation is highly increased in
Parkinson's disease patients and strike
time is is longer and it's primarily due
the due to the fact that Parkinson's
disease patients have a longer dwell
time on the on their two feet in the
middle of their gait and that's also
hypothesized that it is a it makes them
a larger risk for falling here's another
very interesting metric by Horak and
Mancini that this is from a 30-second
quiet stance and you can clearly see
when compared the healthy controls you
begin to see a difference in a lot much
larger radii in controlling your center
of mass and Parkinson's these patients
and it keeps changing when they go on
levodopa it gets even larger and when
they're on the foot you know the full
the peak dosage of levodopa you can see
the quiet stand is has gotten quite big
and it's hypothesized that this is also
correlated to when they have bouts of
dyskinesia and then they go on deep
brain stimulation this is a therapy that
counteracts the side effects of levodopa
it is having electrodes in the brain
connected to a pacemaker that silences
the neurons are causing the the
uncontrollable motor movements that we
call dyskinesia yes i know i'm not a
similar parkinson's disease as
parkinson's disease always affect i mean
long-term affects the entire body but in
early pain in her in
and early symptoms does it tend to
affect the entire body or can it
reprimand fest in just a single whim you
know half of the body it's exactly right
it manifests differently in different
people and that's why we need these more
sensitive measures that's that's what
we're trying to get it we need to figure
out what what are the phenotypes you
know they currently there there's this
hypothesis that there are tremor
dominant Parkinson's disease patient and
what's called posture instability and
gate difficulty but you know depending
on what data set you look at some of
these subcategories hold and some some
don't and we need to get more specific
and this is the hope of what we can
achieve with body-worn sensors now using
the two instruments that I just showed
you the the the at-home device and then
the mobility we did a clinical trial at
the San Francisco VA hospital where we
had patients with the deep brain
stimulators and we blinded them and we
changed the voltage randomly to see if
when you know its proposal if you lower
the dosage lower the voltage that's the
same as kind of akin to lowering the
medication on the patient right and a
much much faster feedback right and lo
behold it did it did hold so this is
very interesting and as you see the
updrs scores go down as the voltage of
this voltage is reduced and you know
same with this dexterity and mobility
so where do we take this you know we're
always asked by pharmaceutical companies
have these measures been validated that
you know it has this become the standard
and it's very difficult because when
you're trying to compare yourself the
updrs it's kind of akin to calibrating
GPS against the sextant I love getting
the smiles from our physical therapists
they know what I'm talking about so
really what we're trying to do is we
want to stratify and figure out what
what are the subtypes of Parkinson's
disease patients and as many of you said
before you know it's time to take the
stuff out of the lab and into the real
world environment so we are working and
contracted with the Intel Corporation
we're developing a platform for wearable
sensors and we have a goal to instrument
a thousand Parkinson's disease patients
by the end of this year and currently
we're working with a system where the
patient is our paradigm current
experimental paradigm is with a a
smartphone that's worn on the hip and a
pebble watch and we've which we have
programmed to sample at 50 Hertz and
it's will be constantly taking in arm
swing measures and gate measures and
communicating via low-power bluetooth to
the smart phone a smart phone has the
accelerometer and gyroscope on
persistently and we're hoping to get
recurrently we're running a small
clinical trial with 50 patients at Mount
Sinai and Harvard University and an
intelligent gate dynamics and also
activities of daily living it's it is an
exercise in labeling the specific
signals this to actions of the patient
so the protocol is fairly detailed where
we're having them you know sit stay
lay down walk climb stairs and video
taking them in the clinic and mapping
the signals to the activity and then we
have the patience go and take the set of
devices in the home and have you know
going to having a very detailed
self-reported diary and what they do by
the hour and there they do this for 48
hours and then come back to the clinic
and do another set of motor goat we put
them through another motor test battery
and then we have another clinical trial
we should be done with this by next
month and the following month we'll have
a levodopa response trial will will
actually try to see if the algorithm
that's that we built in this one will be
able to detect the changes from the
response to deliver dopa and if we were
able to do that we'll have our first
version of the platform ready for
research groups that want to quickly
deploy wearable sensors for research by
the middle of this summer watching yeah
for now but I want to stress to you that
we are intention is to be hardware
agnostic right we're going to be picking
up we're going to be characterizing what
do the signals from accelerometers and
gyros look like and you know this is the
where you wear them in the position of
the body matter all that much we're
going to get smarter about it currently
we're having issues with battery life
which is no surprise you know you have
your gyroscope on so we're we're trying
to figure out the the right optimization
to make this happen
with companies like Nike or Phillips has
an active link product where they're
essentially activity monitors with
multiple accelerometers gyroscopes in
them and they have they've done their
own work at least from what I've read
and trying to determine you know was i
running was I walking was like bicycling
without user input has there been any
collaboration with commercial companies
in terms of getting who have already
been working in the space in some regard
I actually the watch that I'm wearing
right now is called the basis watch and
it and it's a it's the first of its kind
it it has a an optic sensor in the back
so it's a heart rate monitor it measures
my skin temperature it knows how much I
how much perspiration there is at any
given time they produce algorithms it
knows when I'm walking running and
riding a bicycle which i think is pretty
incredible and then it they have a
really good algorithm that we just
proved that it is ninety-two percent as
accurate as a poly sauna graph so I
could go up on the web and I could show
you later my sleep patterns whether I'm
in light sleep deep sleep or in REM
sleep and sleep REM sleep disturbance is
a big formal signal for Parkinson's
disease so we're hoping in the future
we'll get the api's for this device and
be able to incorporate it into this
platform but in terms of you know the
consumer our intention is also we don't
want to reinvent the wheel we want to be
able to use consumer level devices you
know and it makes sense from us cost of
the support standpoint and so this is
this is the level so you can see on the
scale this is the macro level reporting
this is the preprocessed information and
up here is raw data okay for Parkinson's
disease it's going to be somewhere
in this spectrum because we need to we
need to be able to pick up parkinsonian
tremor which is anywhere from three to
seven Hertz right in the current Fitbit
realm that's not available they just
pre-processed information to tell you
the number of steps that you've taken
and how long have you been walking and
that's all pre-processed and it's very
efficient you know it's it doesn't take
up much power but then again we're not
sure whether this information is going
to give us the data that we need now
long-term I could see the correlation
Bureau if your your your gait speed is
slow as a parkinsonian patient it's
going to reflect here but it's going to
take us a lot longer to figure out how
well it correlates to you know those
symptoms so we're working at this level
right now and we're trying to get
systems to work at this level and in
regards to how we're going to deploy we
intend to deploy this tool are currently
sponsored observational clinical trials
but also we want to take another
revolutionary step and we're going to be
launching something that's called Fox
insight which is a patient registry
think of it as a PatientsLikeMe site
where you patients could come in
register they could do an online version
of the updrs put their their medical
information there and then as a part of
the sign up they get to either get
devices from us or download our app and
get hooked into our network and the
benefits will be that for clinical
trials week when we were when we refer
them to clinical trials in the future
all right we'll have the most well
characterized baseline of patients ever
for these for pharmaceutical companies
right we'll have we'll have a really
accurate cohort but also we could we'll
be able to track patients across
clinical trials because we will be all
growing the same level of sensors as
just a check bark box it says what
clinical trial have you been
participating in source stuff you know
being a part of your cure you'll be
actually hot taking a role in it would
be very very rewarding for individuals
absolutely but not only that they get a
benefit out of it too because we'll be
presenting their information back to
them that makes clinical sense
clinically relevant information we get
more insight into their own disease and
be able to work with their neurologists
to say this is exactly how i've been
doing they won't they won't have to go
through to the very difficult task of
trying to articulate have they been
doing in the last six months whether
their medications been working or not
their doctors will have this information
before they come into the office and say
okay you know looks like my rent sleep
is going down so we got to do something
so this is this is the paradigm we're
going to try to hit a thousand patients
by the end of this year and we'll share
our data and please contribute with your
ideas we're really looking forward to
working with you yes what wires the
Dutchman are these buses in your
registry to collect
absolutely like no but I know Parker's
disease patients suffer from dystonia
you know in different parts of the body
and in pain it's a very important
component of their well-being so well do
I think we do have that how much
difficulty try and get you the ice or
your approach as it seems like you're
trying to move this as an outcome right
so it's not not making a primary measure
you're not you're not we're nothing this
is just a patient registry it's going to
give them added information my base is
this company is already kind of
presenting this kind of information on
the web today actually I could show you
you know it's just a matter of how
people use this data I think it will
prove itself over time at least that is
the hope will gain some insights see
okay so this is my basis i'm going to
show you my information
there we go
okay so this is me let's look for some
interesting information here I'll show
you the level at which this is able to
track me alright so let's see the
depressing part is you get to see how
inactive i bin let me find let me find a
more a more rich experience period okay
so here's activity here I do some
walking here way all of them fine fine
where I actually go bicycling that's
more interesting there it's been a very
busy couple of weeks okay I'm trying to
justify my inactivity to you so right
now right here this is this is my
average heart rate throughout the day
you can see how it goes up when I go
bicycling okay um the number of steps
I've taken the average number of steps
this is the calories that have been
expended different parts of the parts of
the day my skin temperature and my
perspiration so you could see it's it's
kind of interesting you know my my how
you could see how well the body
regulates in a healthy person relatively
healthy person units it my body
temperature is pretty consistent but you
know my perspiration keeps it under
control when I go do some strenuous
activity right but this is an autonomic
symptom that goes awry and Parkinson's
disease patients so we'll be able to see
that with this kind of device these
breed of devices that are coming out in
the next six months more interesting is
I'll show you some data from sleep which
i think is very very telling
okay this is a very bad sleep score
thirty two percent this is light this is
deep and this is the amount of REM sleep
that I've got been getting and so you
know Ram is is garbage collection of the
the brain so you know you're thankfully
I've got twenty one percent and say any
in a healthy range it's anywhere from
fifteen to twenty percent so I feel I
feel happy about that at least even
those very very reduced sleep so this is
this is what the future holds right you
know right now I mean I think we all are
agree that gate is is a window into
cognition and now you know in the future
these body warmth sensors will be able
to look into the autonomic functions of
patients and and see how it relates to
your health and what I hope we could see
technologies like Kinect help is give us
validation in the home to tell us is
what we're seeing in these sensors what
we think we're seeing any sensors
actually happening so yes
this is not related to talk it's just
out of curiosity I heard in recent years
as accumulated evidence Parkinson
disease starts on the body and not from
the birth something about the gooey
bodies set up phone and it was
previously found in in the area of the
brain in the hope for the any operations
that are measured up to you publishing
disease and now they actually finds I
mean the body before they find them in
the bird you're absolutely right this is
by a scientist by the name Brock and his
he has brought this hypothesis probably
seven years ago which has gained a lot
of popularity and consensus amongst the
scientific community that Parkinson's
disease may may start in the gut and
work its way up through the the vagus
nerve and finally into the into the
brain and there's statistical evidence
that kind of supports that where it's
it's known that bouts of constipation is
is correlated to Parkinson's disease you
know constipation failure of hype osmia
the ability to smell and sleep
disturbance maybe early indicators of
the disease you know do you have any um
socialist such as opposed to looking
plan because it might be you know that
you know it in front concentration
absolutely so where you know in our in
our in our observational clinical trials
we have one that's called the
Parkinson's progression markers
initiative close to about 700 patients
in early state of the disease and also
patient to our high risk for Parkinson's
disease or participating we take their
blood samples regal spinal fluid urine
MRI scans dopamine transporter scans and
put them through the updrs and a number
of cognitive test batteries at time zero
three months six months and 12 months
and then once a year thereafter for five
years hoping to see this kind of signal
and and you know it kind of highlights
the challenge really this is why we're
going after wearable sensors because
even with that amount of data when you
try to do a it's it's unwell even with
that amount of data it's still under a
million data points and that's hardly
enough to do machine learning algorithms
to find any kind of inference what's
going on we're hoping that if we add you
know wearable sensors you know just in
four hours we get five million data
points and so we were hoping we add
these wearable sensors to those patients
with this rich biological data will
finally have the discriminatory power to
be able to pinpoint how the disease is
progressing
high risk the ice and genetics there's a
genetics cohort things like there's a
lrrk2 it's a gene that's prevalent in
the Ashkenazi Jewish population in the
northern African Berber population
they're part of one of the cohorts and
our observational studies so we're
looking at that yes have you thought
about it in addition to kind of just
tracking patients but using as
accelerometers actually look at a kind
of effectiveness of l-dopa treatment and
in some of these patients because I know
over time as you continue to treat with
Eldo but there becomes a point work
l-dopa doesn't really provide the same
benefit so could you use that the
wearable sensor system to kind of track
when maybe a patient is starting to
plateau or in the other hand there's
certain patients that just don't respond
period to give me l-dopa so if you know
instead of giving somebody else over for
a month if you could just give it to
them and then monitor their progress and
then over a period of three four days
you could kind of see if there is a risk
oh absolutely i mean i think i think
that's one of the real immediate
benefits of the system right where well
one of what what the currently kind of
the acid test to see whether someone
actually has Parkinson's disease versus
you know multiple system atrophy is
levodopa challenge so if they respond to
levodopa then it's a pretty good
indication you know having bradykinesia
rigidity and a tremor if you have those
three symptoms and you respond to
levodopa then you your classified as the
Parkinson disease patient and the key to
improving one's quality of life has
everything to do with proper timing of
levodopa so no its you could have a dose
a dosage recommended dosage per day for
of levodopa but how you administer
throughout the day makes it every bit of
difference in the world you know
making sure you don't take it too close
to when you're eating a sub meal that's
high in protein for instance and just
making sure that you know you're you try
to do your best to bio mimic the release
of dopamine in your body is response to
levodopa as much as you can and it's a
right now it's an art among neuro
neurologists so hopefully with this kind
of system that could be where all the
time that's invisible to the public is
something that'll really help patients
talk to mr. Jones say doing a DBS in
Brighton assimilation and he said the
modus operandi country that patients
found everything Mars to his love she is
the amount of voltage selected
eloquently mr. Thwaites is that the gold
would actually be some some dynamic and
automatic a tuning of the voltage along
the day several days which we increase
the quality of life
during this line of questions so is it
currently focusing just on 1-click data
also are you looking into the closed
control loop scenario which is where you
were talking about going to take that
outdoor bath so when part of the study
allow for someone to say oh I think that
if you were just talking that's a good
time to take the next closest or
something like that so doing something
rising children right I think that
that'll be a feature in the future but
to that point i think when we provide
this information in a dashboard to
patients they'll be able to work with
our neurologist to figure that out much
better than they have been able to do so
before but you know if we could you know
figure out the algorithm of how do how
do you know what is the ultimate dosage
depending on the type of patient and
that's so that's something that we are
going after to as well so look forward
to i will be making the data available
take down our data and tell us what you
see thank you very much